welcome to this video when playing
Guinea feed master from the acid from
the u.s. to 148 this song playing a
color set up the appt at an interesting
one with Safari let's see i get i can
play with g6 this is an old favorite go
in here to get the game a little bit
more a bit more interesting yeah the
question is after that I can take on d5
p.m. you know I will okay it's going for
that takes on g6 of funny tactical
sequence damn it leads to on this
interesting structure where black needs
to do something about the descent palm
the normal way to go about it is to play
the Queen to e6 and try to exchange
Queens which normally leads to a
satisfactory position I wonder here take
a look aged five maybe is this an idea
Joe not sure okay let's let's go with
the originally intended move trying to
get them get the Queen off from d 5 i'll
simply exchange it okay he wants to take
with the pawn which is a bit surprising
I mean rook takes I'll go night before I
just win the a two point
I thought that the pawn on d5 is rather
weakness but maybe he's got something
with rookie one okay it's not even
thinking about it Oh came here maybe
rookie one rookie one king da Bishop g5
check mm mama did shouldn't that should
lead to much he's got a very weak back
rank they are still but why should it
must be a bit careful here I can hmm
okay I go for that so that i have d 7
for the king and i always have rook age
5 just ruining this pot and I don't see
how he prevented I I don't really know
he may be should play Bishop be too warm
get rid of the bishop yeah this is a
good idea so that furious
now that's very surprising i mean now i
have king d76 and so on
I thought that just helps black
enormously even the deep part is
completely it's not dangerous at all
yeah you do need to take it now get the
King involved yeah the thing is you can
play ha5 let's see jump but i can i can
on a file i play rugby aid and if it
tries to win it is still has the week
back rank to worry about that's rogue
age 5 in addition this idea okay no
moves left on not really sure maybe
going in here ok I'm just going to play
my stuff here I don't expect any move so
just go ahead attack a form on a five I
played b5 and I have two connected
passes yeah he's got this passive move
of course let's see okay rook d 4 wins
the d5 pawn I guess yeah it's one good
good way to play
not sure that is the best move from a
technical point of view it's certainly
not bad I mean but not sure if it's the
best one maybe I can first player play
some moves to to strengthen my position
even it's also an idea to play c4 and
rook c8 c5 and then take the pawn maybe
rook rook over here and now no I'm going
for that if he takes pawn takes he's got
the passive rook it cannot go to the C
file yeah this is good it's probably
probably convincing I will take d5 next
and then I have also look III with the
tempo if he moves the rope from the
third-ranked yeah this is good I played
kingdom five King c4d three NT sir it
does not really have any anything to
play against it
yeah that's a bit strange you went to
right into the bed end game with BB take
c5 if you place Bishop b2 I think it's
yeah it looks it looks very comfortable
for black but it's not not like
completely terrible and in the game it
was terrible yeah okay d 2 is playing
rugby one this is not great so what is
the easiest way maybe just here and yeah
I take a six so probably easiest on a
six the rook is also covering g6 and I
can push the deep on later anyway yeah d
2 it's probably also winning now okay
let's just grab this
basically just winning a temple to go to
see form and group is six is coming next
check time warning
ok check
check check check check white resigns
yeah let's uh let's recap the skin until
here we are we are within theoretically
explored waters but I don't I don't know
rock group be one that's already a bit
strange but ok maybe yeah the thing is
that this is just a big porn I mean it's
a something that you really must be
cautious about and my king unless it is
a problem immediately then my king is
great on the aid it can join the action
quickly and he must be precise here yeah
funny enough how the engine is already
giving black very substantial edge yes
expect it I suspected that but as usual
you cannot be completely sure ok played
the capture and before yet these things
is clear and no other captures is a
clear mistake I mean I thought that if
you go here that you can cure that you
can still play that the thing is that
the black is still just better I've got
to the king in play and I've got the
potential oops potential passer here his
pawn no this is basically the h-bond
I've traded an important queenside porn
for the H pawn and it's a long way from
him to get a passer himself so this is
some just not not great minus one has
the engine evaluation
this is this is even worse as now I've
got two passes or almost too almost too
slowly aive technically that's the
airport but time yeah and important I go
to the 60 i play with an extra pc other
King and computers on minus two points
something already this is just a win and
it was some and there were multiple ways
to play it i mean not sure that i
actually played the best one but it
always it always kept kept the winning
hand i think probably here there was
something something easier an important
thing is to just check check not spoil
the overall win and play play it safe
it's not bad in bits yeah here why does
this out of ideas really and could have
resigned but okay sometimes you just
play on Frank alright alright thanks for
watching